Gravity
is working with me
And Gravity,
keeps me on the ground
All mass attracts
all other mass
a force proportional
to mass one and two
and inversely to
the distance between them squared
Oh, gravity
is working with me
and gravity,
makes apples fall to ground
Oh twice the mass
has twice the pull
but the force on each
is still equal
It keeps the moon
and the satellites
going round
Oh twice the mass
has twice the pull
but the force on each
is still equal
It keeps the moon
and the satellites
going round
Oh gravity,
the force that makes weight on me
Woah, gravity,
now general relativity
(how can that be?)
The force between us all is
Gravity between us all is
Gravity between gravity between us all is